it is one of the most important
decisions a parent can make finding the
right daycare for their child but right
now it's the daycares with an important
decision finding staff john langler
shares how they're dealing with this
work shortage and enticing candidates
[Music]
local day cares i spoke with say it's as
bad as it's ever been staff are hard to
find hard to hire and hard to keep it's
a national problem especially when by
law child care facilities have to have
enough workers for the families they
serve
at dayton ohio's victorium learning
center they take pride in providing
consistency we will get a handle on this
overall director lauren nelson says
they've maintained weekly and daily
cleaning routines sanitizing every touch
surface every touch you know area
students follow a hand washing schedule
it's almost like a stop drop and roll
but where we're stop dropping and we're
washing our hands we're scrubbing them
up we're you know we're abc but the
center is not immune to staffing
challenges we
have struggled with finding high quality
educators
really to meet the demands of of that
child care dennis grant leads united
rehabilitation services he says it's
best defense are vaccinations
95 of our staff are currently vaccinated
and we are very happy about that and
actually we're thrilled to death that
over 90 percent of the adults with
disabilities we serve in our day program
are also vaccinated they also have a
very strict screening policy screening
individuals when they attend whether
adults or children
and also screening their family members
or the people who transport them but
this day cares only at 65 percent of
normal enrollment without any additional
staff we have two classrooms that are
closed one of our preschool classrooms
as well as one of our infant rooms the
center is working on ways to help head
start students keep their masks on we
can't give them treats and snacks and
candy throughout the day but we can give
them a lot of stickers here in las vegas
daycares are trying to increase pay to
entice people to apply the only problem
in some cases applicants just don't show
up john langler live local now